so were you like were you ever angry
before you were a monk
because i swear i've never seen you
angry what's up with that gun i mean i
i i've been angry before i felt like you
get mildly frustrated you don't get even
when you're angry i'm like dude
i don't know if you're angry angry no
like like
being a monk just taught me how to deal
with it think about
the whole process basically process
everything right because when
when you just kind of empty your mind
you part part of part of the uh
commitment we try to make is that we try
to learn how we
process our way of thinking and you
gotta like you gotta
kind of it's it i okay so the way i see
it it's kind of like a logic tree
right and and and and this is what
happened to me when i was a monk where
i'd feel certain emotions and you'd have
to like logically think
be like why am i feeling this why am i
feeling this how did this come
and then you kind of learned the roots
of basically all your emotions and just
anger and then
through that i just on the fly i learned
how to deal with my anger and just
and just i would find another route to
be like okay before i get angry maybe i
could go
maybe i could try dealing it with
another way which is why i rarely get
angry
um and i always you know some people get
angry very easily
um but for me it's not that i don't get
angry is that i just have different ways
of dealing about it
then of course than shouting or [ __ ]
death i just love shouting man
okay i don't punch anyone anymore that's
old
old con is gone new connor he just wears
cosplays and shouts loudly
i love shouting i love like when i shout
i [ __ ] love shouting
i don't know why shouting is so fun like
so do you like purposely shout to just
get like
that frustration now before it turns
into legit anger or
sometimes if i'm like real angry some
days or i wake up and i'm upset i'll
just go in the mirror
and i'll be like come on
i only hear i only say that like movies
all right
[ __ ] i wouldn't be surprised if you're
the kind of person who just like punches
their pillow
frustration out but i just imagined you
in the [ __ ] morning every every
morning
okay like like in the mirror god you got
you got this kind of okay
some days you wake up right you're
feeling like man i feel kind of
kind of shitty today man like i don't
know why man i'm kind of worthless right
i get in front of that mirror i'm like
you got this
okay my neighbors probably hate me [ __ ]
it i'm hyped i'm ready for the day
that that energy rushes through you i
feel like i feel like
i feel like i feel like a 10 immediately
it's so monkey
i love it oh my god i'm feeling intense
straight away this is the start of my
day uh
quest question to you guys how do you
guys hype yourself up before recording
session
for your videos because there's going to
be a time
okay okay this is the thing that shane i
think this is because you're you've
you've just recently started doing it a
lot right yeah because i remember when i
first started filming my face a lot i
[ __ ] dreaded doing it oh yeah and i
did everything to avoid it i would be
like i would shave like three times
just to make sure it was perfect in my
head but recent but really what i was
doing was delaying it yeah yeah yeah
like oh my god maybe i need to go get
the groceries actually
i should do laundry action oh it's too
late to focus yeah
oh i can't recall because i was too busy
renovating my house
yeah but now now i just [ __ ] turn it
on and do it i don't already think about
it yeah i don't really
i don't really hype myself i should have
a coffee maybe a red bull if i need it
but that's about it yeah
caffeine helps definitely but i don't i
don't really have like a do it phase you
know
in the morning if you're feeling down
man try it next time okay
next time you feel sad right and you
wake up because it happens sometime man
you just feel shitty
just try it you'll feel like an idiot at
first
but then you'll be like nice dude aki's
going to clown on me
i was about to say sydney's going to be
like no one lives with me so it's like
yeah
yeah you can do it by yourself but it's
like city's like god what are you doing
who are you saying come on do it do it
don't let your dreams come on
[Laughter]
i i realize i'm slowly forming a profile
for me of just like
a complete monkey